Очільник Чечні Рамзан Кадиров знову зажадав від українського президента
"підтвердити вибачення" за сатиричний ролик, оприлюднений ще 2014-го року,
коли Зеленський очолював "Квартал-95".
Тоді кадри президента Чечні зі сльозами на очах під час мусульманського намазу
супроводжували жарти на тему знесення пам'ятника Леніну в Харкові.
При цьому раніше Зеленський уже вибачався за це.
Нові претензії з Грозного офіційний Київ поки не коментує,
а тим часом Сполучені Штати запровадили проти Кадирова нові санкції.
- такими словами, а також фотографією на тлі стелажів
зі зброєю і двома автоматами в руках прокоментував Рамзан Кадиров
інформацію про нові санкції, які на нього та його родину наклали США.
Чергові обмеження поширюються не лише на главу Чечні,
але і на його дружину Медні Кадирову і доньок.
Санкції полягають у забороні на в'їзд у США.
Причиною, як стверджують у Держдепартаменті,
стали численні порушення прав людини протягом останніх 10 років,
У тому числі тортури та позасудові страти, які посилилися останніми місяцями.
У правозахисному центрі "Меморіал" вважають, що
нові американські санкції пов'язані не стільки з останніми подіями,
скільки з загальною трагічною ситуацією з правами людини
в Чечні протягом останнього десятиліття.
Ситуація з правами людини в Чечні гіршою вже не може бути.
Я повторюю: в Чечні права людини не тільки не дотримуються,
а грубо нехтуються вже багато-багато років.
Це вже не перші міжнародні санкції проти Рамзана Кадирова, його родини та оточення.
З 2014 року Кадиров - у списку санкцій Євросоюзу за дії,
які загрожують територіальній цілісності України,
а 2017-го главу Чечні Сполучені Штати включили до так званого "списку Магнітського"
за вбивства і тортури в республіці.
Торік США вирішили взятися за фінанси Кадирова.
Тоді Палата представників американського Конгресу
ухвалила резолюцію з приводу вбивства Бориса Нємцова,
яка передбачає пошук активів Кадирова за межами Росії,
особливо в Саудівській Аравії та Об'єднаних Арабських Еміратах.
Втім, кажуть у "Меморіалі", відчутного ефекту нові візові санкції не принесуть.
Зрозуміло, що ці санкції, які зараз були застосовані,
вони мають суто символічний характер.
Ані Кадиров, ані люди з його родини та, думаю,
і з найближчого оточення у США не збиралися і не збираються їхати.
Але санкції, як будь-які символічні кроки, важливі.
Санкції США і відповідь Кадирова прокоментувала й Москва.
Прессекретар Путіна Дмитро Пєсков заявив, що
у Кремлі не бачать проблем у фотографії Кадирова зі зброєю, якщо ця зброя легальна.
У свою чергу, офіційний представник МЗС Росії Марія Захарова
пообіцяла "дзеркальну відповідь" Росії на цей крок США.